Wow!
Hello!
Hello, everybody!
Welcome to another day of Mechabreak!
Alright, let me get the game out.
Alright, so, I forgot to save the sound settings for Mechabreak.
And I don't know if my sound team are alive right now.
That's the only issue.
So, I guess we're gonna freestyle it.
Wait, unless...
It's staff... I could get the other... I could get the other staff team to help me out.
The other mod team.
Um, this is your time to shine, staff team!
That aren't... Oh, wait, no, no.
Never mind.
We have a sound guy that's alive.
JK, you're not promoted, mod team!
You're not...
JK!
We have... We have someone alive.
I see them typing.
They're like, I just woke up.
Give me a minute.
Promotion denied.
With no... It's okay.
It's those type of promotions where you get a fancier title, but you don't get paid any extra work.
You do extra work, but you just don't get paid for it.
You just get the title.
Hello, everybody!
Hello, and welcome to another stream for Mechabreak.
For those who are new here, this is a sponsored stream.
I am sponsored by Mechabreak.
They asked me to stream one more.
Um, I... I was gonna do two streams, but I'll be doing another stream after this stream on Tuesday for Mechabreak.
Um, because they enjoyed... They enjoyed the first stream, so they asked me to do an extra one, um, to promote the game.
And the Mechabreak has been really fun!
Um, I actually, uh, I... I wish I did have time to, like, actually, like, play around with all the other characters.
But legitimately, after the first Mechabreak stream, it was just work, work, work, work, work, until the birthday stuff.
And then I did not exist as a person yesterday.
Other than the Chibi-Doki collab, I was not, like, like, existing at all.
I just, like, right after the collab, I, like, I, like, it was, like, offline mode.
You can tell, because I still have yet to...
I still have yet to tweet out anything related to my birthday stuff.
So, like, you know, my new outfit references, I haven't even tweeted that out.
I haven't even tweeted out the birthday kick.
I haven't tweeted out any thank you tweets yet.
Um, I'm so out of it.
I've been awake since 9, 9.30 a.m.
Because I had to do my meet and greets at Anime Expo.
And, um, and also, like, uh, you know, doing this sponsored stream today, too.
But Monday, there will be no stream.
Anyway, guys, uh, for those who don't know what Mechabreak is, it is a third-person hero shooter.
I mean, it has, like, three different game modes.
But, uh, it's a third-person Mecha shooter.
And, um, and basically, there's three game modes.
It's Extraction, uh, 6v6 hero shooter, and, uh, 3v3 deathmatch.
And there's, like, 12 characters that you can pick right now.
And then it's free to play, guys.
This is free to play.
So, if you do exclamation point Mecha or see the pinned, uh, the pinned, uh, comment in, uh, the chat, uh, you can actually download it right now for free.
And, you know, play the game.
I'm gonna be doing a few custom lobbies later on.
Um, I think, like, at the last hour or so.
Um, because this will be a two-hour stream.
Um, and the first hour, I'll be playing the, um, you know, the quick play, the 3v3, and the regular.
I think a lot of people, I think people actually know how to play now.
So, I'm pretty sure, I'm pretty sure, um, a lot of people know how to play this game now.
So, it's gonna be a lot difficult.
So, I can't get away with stuff these days.
Yeah, so, yeah, I'm not playing extraction.
Because, uh, I personally don't like extraction game modes in general.
Like, it doesn't matter what game that tries to do extraction mode for me.
I'm not, like, a huge extraction player.
Um, I, if I had to choose between, like, extraction, uh, hero shooter, or, like, 3v3, um, I would obviously go for it.
Like, because there's so many choices.
There's three game choices and everything.
So, that's why I'll go with, um, hero shooter.
But if you are an extraction player, I heard the extraction game mode is, like, pretty fun.
So, of course, you guys can check it out as well.
Um, uh, Nurukami.
Bro, I still love, I love Nurukami.
Nurukami is, like, such a fun character to play.
I should try the other characters, but I feel like they're not as good as Nurukami.
The heavy sniper?
Oh, okay.
I'll see what the heavy sniper is.
And someone's like, and plus, she is hot.
Try Akila.
Uh, Akila?
Okay, I'll try her, too.
Um, but yeah.
Anyway, I hope you guys, uh, I hope you guys enjoy more Mecha Break streams.
Yeah!
Uh, blah, blah, blah.
All right, let's get started.
Uh, blah, blah, blah, blah.
All right.
Okay, sound guy.
You're gonna have to, like, uh, Discord message me about the sound stuff, too.
All right.
Oh, yeah.
By the way, for those who don't know, by watching, you get Twitch drops.
So don't worry, guys.
I will show you, uh, I'll show you the Twitch drops.
Let me see.
Sorry, that's Starscream.
I, uh, Starscream showed up on the images instead of the, uh, instead of the Twitch drops because I was showing people, um, Windblade's Starscream version earlier to, yesterday.
I was, like, earlier to, wait, no.
I'm, like, losing track of, like, time.
So you can be a cat girl, um, by watching this stream today, um, and getting, uh, you know, and getting these Twitch drops.
So you can have, like, you can be a cat girl.
Look, there's the cat tail, too.
The cybermedic tail.
Look at that.
You, too, can become Dolkitty, uh, if you watch my stream right now.
Alright.
It's been a while.
I'm, I'm, let's see if I remember the controls.
Okay.
What's, what's the heavy sniper's name?
Oh, Akilah.
Okay.
That's her.
Apparently, she's fun to play, too.
So.
So, let's see.
Have I tried her?
I must have tried her, right?
Because I, I didn't have to unlock her.
Unless I, once?
Yeah?
Let's see.
Uh, I'll look at the, I'm gonna look at the practice range.
I feel like I've tried her because I didn't have to unlock her.
Oh, there's matchmaking mode now.
Oh, there's casual and matchmaking now.
For those who, like, don't want to.
Oh, that's cool.
Okay, they, they put it.
Now, you can actually play rank or casual.
Alright, I might.
It'll depend on how much they fuck me up.
Alright, let's see.
I want, I don't remember.
Yeah, there's a casual mode now.
And a rank mode.
Oh, was this the very first mecha I tried?
Yeah, I was gonna say.
I must have tried her before.
Oh, it's the shield girl, right?
I don't remember her stuff, though.
Alright, uh...
Let's see.
F...
2.
Okay, F2.
Alright.
Sniper mode.
Close range mode.
Fires.
Plasma beam.
Inflicting direct energy damage.
Fires.
No, no.
Okay.
Is this actually?
No, I feel like...
There's the hover forever.
Airborne grants hovering ability.
Enhancing mobility.
Pulse claw releases tracking drones that lock into the target.
Immobilizing and halting energy regen.
Immobilizing, uh...
Uh...
And then three.
Multi-lock radar.
Uh, reticle size boost lock speed and...
Oh, it's the first one from training.
Oh!
I see.
Um...
Press again to deactivate early and reduce cooldown.
Okay.
Uh...
Boost lock speed and reload speed for...
Press to...
Okay, so...
Regular is...
Activate sniper mode.
Increase flyer's plasma beam.
Okay.
I see.
Alright.
Let's look at...
Let's do training settings real quick.
Uh...
It doesn't really matter who I get.
Alright.
Yeah, someone...
Okay.
And then...
I can hover like this.
Okay.
And then...
What is...
This is like...
It doesn't do energy regen.
Okay.
Alright.
She seems pretty easy.
Okay.
Let's try her out in rank.
Uh...
In rank.
Alright.
I...
Like, her kit is like super easy...
To like...
Figure out in general.
So...
There's not like too much...
Too much to think about.
Which is good.
Because like...
There's nothing in my head right now.
Oh, good news.
The brain fog is...
Um...
Decreasing.
Right?
It's crazy.
It's like...
You know...
I'm not stressed out anymore.
And it's like...
The brain fog is...
It's actually...
Uh...
Fading away.
So...
Is that fucking crazy?
I'm not like stressed out over like a birthday...
Dreams and concerts and outfit reveals.
All on like two days.
And now the brain fog is sort of...
Getting...
Like fading away.
Yippee!
Oh my god.
I just slept in too.
I've...
For some reason...
Dad has...
Has only woken me up...
For food.
And that's it.
And then so like...
He let me sleep in.
Um...
He basically has been letting me sleep in...
The last two days.
And I'm like...
I don't know what's happening.
I...
Like...
I wish he would do that...
When I was going through that...
You know...
The concert planning.
I wish he would...
You know...
Not be...
Waking me up...
Every hour...
When that was happening.
But for some fucking reason...
After my birthday...
He's like...
You know what?
You deserve it.
You...
You know what?
You fucking deserve it.
Jokey.
I'm like...
That's cool.
Maybe you should have...
Let me sleep.
Before then...
Before I was like...
You know...
When I needed to sleep...
To do all this work stuff.
Uh...
Oh, it was so kind of him.
You know...
So very kind.
Alright.
Let's try this out.
We'll do matchmaking.
Because like...
Our ELO is low.
Right?
I assume our ELO is low.
Hmm.
Alright.
Very cool, Dad.
Very cool.
I gotta keep track of the time too.
To make sure...
Uh...
We don't go...
We don't forget about the custom lobbies.
Alright.
Hound Master.
Oh, there's me!
Aquila!
That's me!
Narukami!
Oh my god!
Serpentine!
Thank you for 10 gifted subs!
Thank you!
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much!
How many snipers do we have?
Okay, no.
You don't...
I feel like this game doesn't need support.
Like, it's literally just fragging.
Maybe it's because it's a low ELO.
Like...
But I feel like I've only seen one support since...
The last...
The two times I've been playing this game.
Like...
I don't know.
I feel like I have not seen a support at all.
Depending on the game mode...
Oh, you definitely need support.
Which game mode requires support the most?
Pilot proceeding on board.
Actually, very good.
Oh, when it's 3v3.
Oh, supports are not easy to play.
Oh, don't tell necros that.
I don't know.
I just haven't seen a support player in many of my lobbies.
But to be fair, like...
They're a rare breed.
Alright, tell me which is the best...
Which is the meta support?
I'll try that one out.
I haven't tried support yet.
And also tank, but I'm never touching tank.
Because, like, what the fuck?
Like...
I feel like...
I don't know.
Tank is like...
That's M territory right there.
Alright.
Oh my god.
It's been a while since I played.
So I'm, like, trying to remember the controls.
Where are they?
Hello, guys.
Hey.
Where's no day?
Oh my god.
There's Sar...
There he is.
Oh my god.
It's so...
Wait, what?
Sorry.
I had to, like, stop myself.
Because I'm, like, I'm sponsored.
You guys can sort of tell I had to stop myself.
I couldn't help it.
There you go.
Close call, guys.
Oh shit.
Oh my god.
Bro.
Okay.
I'm gaming.
Are you stupid?
Bro, are you stupid?
Are you...
Bro.
What are you trying to do?
Oh shit.
I'm stupid.
Okay.
Oh no.
I'm stupid.
Come on.
No!
You're so lucky!
You are so lucky!
Oh my god.
I was ready!
Oh my...
You do not deserve to live.
You really...
I died by gravity.
Truly.
Actually.
A gravity debuff right there.
Where is the objective?
I am not paying attention to that.
You're looking to pick off some stragglers.
Yeah.
You're my own nemesis.
Like gravity.
Don't worry.
I'm heading over to help.
Okay.
Where is it?
Oh my god.
I got that platform!
Nice.
I'm gonna...
Make sure I charge it.
There you go.
God, I'm gaming.
I'm playing for the kills.
Not the...
Not the objective.
Guys, I would say that if I wasn't in rank right now.
Okay?
If I wasn't in rank, I would...
True.
But I'm in rank right now.
So I can't do that.
Oh my god.
Of course.
He dropped.
He dodged it.
Come on.
Get over here.
That's fucking right.
Oh my god.
You're such a little bitch.
Wait, who's that?
Oh, that's a...
That's my team.
Just go for a kill.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I don't...
Hello.
Teammate?
Bro, what the...
Okay.
That was sick.
You gotta admit.
I was like, he must be in that corner.
I...
I knew it.
I was like, okay.
He's definitely in that corner.
Like...
He asked me.
Like, where else would you go?
You about to learn today, son.
Oh my god.
Water?
But I'm a robot.
Okay.
Alright.
Where's the mecha here?
That's right.
I'm here for you.
Where is he?
Oh, there he is.
Oh, you think I...
Oh, that's fucking right.
Oh, oh, that's right.
Whoa.
That's right.
Dodge.
Get dodged.
Get shit on.
They're like, why is she in this elo?
I bet you they're like, bro, what the heck?
Why is this dogey bird in this elo?
They don't know.
I was busy with my birthday, so I couldn't play the game.
Got that water.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh, there's so many people here.
I want...
I want to kill this guy.
There we go.
That's goddamn right.
Get over here.
You're so lucky I have to reload.
What do you mean by low elo?
I'm not supposed to be in this elo.
That's what I mean.
Like, you can tell.
You can tell by how these players are playing.
No!
Guys, what happened to...
Guys, oh my god.
I am actually doing so much for this team.
What are you saying?
I don't know.
Oh my god.
Get out of here.
I'm doing so much.
I'm actually doing so much for this team.
There's no way.
There's no way we're losing this.
I am...
I've been killing people all day.
Oh my god.
You better not die.
That's right.
Oh my god.
You're fucking welcome.
You little guy.
You goddamn welcome.
I guess I'll cap another objective.
Not enough kills.
Like, I'm just saying.
Like, are you serious?
Oh my guys.
I see you.
You're so lucky.
You're so...
Oh my god.
Nice.
Oh, I got you.
Oh my god.
I don't got you.
That's fine.
Oh, that's not fine.
Oh my god.
It's the tank, man.
The tank, man.
Oh my god.
Not the tank, man.
Tank, man.
And...
Skabada-doo.
Okay.
I need help against this guy, though.
Oh my god.
Wait.
Be close range.
Oh my god.
I can't get in there.
That's the worst part.
Oh my god.
I can't go in.
Someone has...
Seriously?
No.
Where's your locket?
Okay.
That's like one thing I keep forgetting to use.
I keep forgetting to use the locket because there's never been a point to...
That's my sniper rushing to the point.
I swear to god.
Their panther was on the hunt.
My kid...
No.
I used much.
Are you...
Bro, my kill.
What do they want from me?
What does my team want?
I have nine kills.
You've done zero objective.
That's on you, girl.
I'm a fragger.
What do you mean?
I frag.
I'm a fragger.
Okay.
All right.
Fuck this guy.
I'm sad.
I'm so sad.
I'm...
What more can I do?
What more can I...
I literally killed everyone.
What more can I do for my team?
What...
That is sad.
I was...
Fragging.
Like hopping between...
People were there capping.
I made sure...
That my team was capping...
Before I left.
Killstall.
One of the games.
Doki.
You know what more you could do?
And I'm not...
Okay.
Oh, wait.
I have to be SVP, right?
Okay.
There we go.
Oh.
I'm not even SVP.
Just because I don't cap the point...
I don't deserve to be MVP.
Bro, I don't even get...
MVP goes to the objective.
That is so...
Oh.
Just because I don't capture the point...
I just don't deserve to be MVP.
That is...
Me?
What?
I am literally...
The sniper.
What am I...
What do you do?
Why would I be on the point?
If I'm...
The sniper.
Literally.
What more can I do for you?
If only you had this point.
Bro.
Wait.
Okay.
Top assault.
Let's see how much damage I've done.
I swear to God.
Okay.
What's my damage?
What is...
I need a...
No.
Oh.
Oh my...
Wait.
What the...
Okay.
Damage taken.
Okay, buddies.
Okay.
Bro.
This guy.
Lord B has done 49,000 damage.
What was your goal here?
I...
I've done...
One, two, three, four.
If you combine four of their players, they still don't equal my damage.
They...
They still...
We got robbed!
We got...
He...
He capped...
But...
But Donkey though...
Look, he captured two points.
Look at your captures.
Zero.
I was robbed!
But did you do the objective, though?
That's it.
I'm going to 3v3.
I'm at it.
If you had someone trying to cap in, this also counts as playing objective.
If I see... I could have all this.
Alright.
Yo, thank you for the hundred bitties!
Thank you, thank you!
Ready to strike.
That's it.
Get ready.
I'm here to snipe again.
I'm going to deathmatch.
There's no objectives in deathmatch.
It's all about killing.
Alright.
Alright, let's see.
I'm bringing up the volume a little more.
Alright, I brought up the volume a little more, sound guy.
Damn those snuck crates.
You're still wearing goddamn objectives now to stop me!
Alright, here I go.
Here I fucking go!
I can't believe it.
I used- I was so happy in the beginning.
I was like, look at me, guys.
Look at me fragging.
Oh, wow!
No, not this map!
Not this map!
No!
Oh, my god!
Oh, my gosh.
I'd think, a little bit.
Can I immobilize him?
No, I didn't want to shoot you.
Okay.
That's fine.
No.
Oh my god.
That was close.
That was not fine.
Oh my god.
Please!
Shoot him!
Oh my god.
Stop flying!
I can't shoot!
There we go.
Oh my god.
It took so long.
I was reloading.
My energy was so low.
He's so lucky.
There's a Nurukami.
I see you.
I know you're here.
Oh god, I'm so- OH SHIT!
SHIT!
Oh my god.
I have to like- OH MY GOD.
I'm still flying.
I'm like this.
I hate this map.
Okay.
Up this.
That's fine.
Haha!
Stay outta here!
Alright.
We're fine.
This map makes me panic so much though.
Like, not gonna lie.
I panic so much.
for this map.
Cause it's so scary.
What?
Oh my god.
Oh!
Is that him?
I don't know.
I can't tell.
Okay.
Nice.
I'm gonna help my team.
That's right!
Locked in!
Aimbot!
That's right!
There's no objective now!
Hahaha!
I'm unstoppable when there's no objective!
No objectives!
Oh my god.
I'm always like, so paranoid.
Hahaha!
That's right!
Here we go.
Get outta here!
Get your ass outta here!
Get out!
Hahaha!
Wait, you're still alive?
You're still alive?
What?
What is that?
What the fuck is that?
Was that- Is that here?
Like, what is that?
Hahaha!
I just don't know what that was!
Oh my god, bro!
That poor guy!
Hahaha!
Oh shit!
Poor ass!
Oh!
Hahaha!
I don't think he knows.
I don't think he knows I'm there.
Hahaha!
He's just- That's right!
No objectives gonna stop me now!
That's right!
Also, Arrow, thank you for the hundred videos!
Thank you!
That's goddamn right!
Ooh!
8-0!
Easy!
I ain't- Okay, I- Yeah, I- I- I didn't get MVP there.
Oh, yeah, that's fine.
That's fine.
You know?
That's okay.
I did my job.
You know?
Oh, just cuz he did more- One kill more than me.
That's- That's fine.
Just cuz- Oh, wait, no.
Just cuz- Wow!
I did so much!
Damage!
Hahaha!
Are you kidding me?
Are you- I- I just- Oh!
Yeah, it was not fine.
It- It was- It was- Not enough.
Okay.
I don't understand!
I got more- Look- Oh, I got- Someone had to whittle those guys down!
Bro, stole your kills and the MVP!
We got robbed!
Hahaha!
That's it.
One less kill.
I can't believe it.
Can't- That's it!
I'm pulling out the- Big boys now!
That's it!
Get outta here!
I'm pulling- I'm pulling out the hot one!
Hahaha!
I'm giving out the really hot one!
That's- God damn it!
Oh my god!
Wait.
I think they- They balanced me.
Oh no.
Wait a minute.
Hahaha!
Wait!
Did I- They- They- Did you see that?
They- They- Did you see that?
500 plus kills?
Wait a minute.
That does- I- I'm in the AP course now.
Oh!
Oh wait.
I think I got auto-balanced.
Hahaha!
Oh that's awkward!
Oh wait.
Wait a minute.
Why this- Guys!
Why do they have 500 plus kills?
Why?
Why- I need a note.
I need a note guys.
Will we be fine?
It's time to find out.
Wait.
I think-
Okay.
Oh shit!
Guys, I don't think we're gonna be fine.
Oh my god.
Guys.
I- I'm a little worried now.
For real.
Hahaha!
Okay.
Okay, nice.
We got one.
I got scared cuz he got close to me.
And we all know what happens when they get too close.
Guys, we all know what happens when they get way too close, guys.
Oh my god.
Wait, what?
Oh, I keep forgetting like- I have like separate ammo.
Okay, nice.
It's fine.
We're fine.
We're so healthy.
Where are they?
Wait, how did we already get four kills?
That's crazy.
That's actually crazy that we have four kills already.
Hahaha!
Bro, I've been matchmaking!
That's the craziest part.
Like- Hahaha!
Hahaha!
Okay!
This might not be fair.
Hahaha!
This might not be fair at all.
In general.
Hahaha!
I don't think this is fair.
Holy shit!
Okay, I'm a little scared now though.
Uh, we're already at one kill.
We're- Hahaha!
We're already- Hahaha!
We're already- Holy shit!
Sky up!
Oh shit!
Nevermind!
Don't worry!
Beat him up again!
Get him in the corner!
Hahaha!
So fast!
What happened?
What happened to this- That was- G- G?
Like- What happened?
What-
What did he- Bro, like- Why did this game?
I'm so confused.
I didn't- Hahaha!
Hahaha!
Everybody was so fast.
We have to say, what is he doing here?
I thought this was rake.
Zero, zero, zero.
Yeah, that was like actually the fastest game of mecha break I've ever played.
2, middle instant equals instant 10.
Hey, hey, hey, look.
I did my job.
Look at...
How did I do the... How did I take the most damage?
These two are melee characters.
How... Why were they... Why were they taking less damage than me?
I don't understand.
Were they not shooting back?
Bro, were they... They didn't... They didn't shoot them.
They didn't... I face tech more than our melee characters.
That's crazy.
Bro, it sucks to be these guys.
These guys were not having a good time for sure.
You caught... They cowered in fear.
I don't know how the fuck you was in my lobby.
That's crazy.
All right.
I'll try a new character.
Okay, guys.
Who's meta in support, guys?
Which support character is meta?
Your bonds?
Yeah, and then we have a GM.
Okay.
What was her name?
Panaka?
This one?
All right.
Who is she?
Oh, it's this one!
All right.
I heard that.
Okay, she's meta.
Apparently, she's really good.
All right.
We'll try her out.
Go.
Yeah, she has... I like her design.
I like the wheel at the back.
Orpheus, thank you for the 100 bitties.
Thank you.
Do the dragoons have a tactical unit?
Oh, wait.
What's that?
How do I play here?
All right.
Rapid repair grappler.
Locks on and fires grappler at friendly target.
Continuously repairing ally.
Lock target required.
Pulls the striker towards the target.
Usable during stagger.
Oh, it pulls me to them.
Okay.
Splitter.
Fires 18 plasma buckshot.
Oh, so that's like a shotgun.
In front of the support.
It fires when emergency support drone is deployed.
It fires in front of the support target instead.
Okay.
Oh, so she's like a mercy then.
Deploys stationary drones to continuously repair friendly units within...
Oh, wait.
I...
Yeah.
So...
Okay.
Um...
Cover airdrop kit.
Deploys a giant shelter that blocks all attacks and hinders enemy movement.
Direct hits bypass fluid...
Cover airdrop deploys a giant shelter that blocks...
Oh!
So she makes covers.
Direct hits bypass things and force fields dealing high physical damage.
So I just fucking drop a giant wall from the sky and then it could hit somebody.
Okay.
Deploys tracking drone to every player is an ally.
Generate a state to block all attacks and grant stagger.
Auto crawls when applies to caster with no target is locked.
Usable during immobilization and stagger.
Okay.
We'll try this out.
Alright.
Uh...
Let's just get that.
Okay, but how do I get like a...
How the fuck do I...
Okay, we need like...
Okay, there we go.
This is my target.
Oh!
I'm like, I'm...
Don't worry, I got you!
I got you!
Okay.
So that heals.
Oh, but...
Okay, so...
And then this one...
Repair drone.
And I can go over here.
And then I'm healing them now.
Okay.
Alright.
And this is...
This is heal?
This isn't heal, right?
And then...
I can drop a wall.
Okay.
The wall!
That's silly.
That's funny.
I like that.
That's pretty funny.
Okay, wait.
Uh...
I wanna drop a wall on someone.
Get over here.
Oh my god.
I missed.
Wait.
How many walls can I make?
Oh my god.
Please drop the wall on her!
Guys!
I need it to be on her!
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
I think I can do like three.
Okay.
And then that's like the force field too.
Oh, I have to hold it.
Oh!
Okay.
The wall!
Oh my god.
I barely do damage though.
I think.
I don't do a lot of...
Wait.
No, I do actually.
Nevermind.
It's because of the armor.
Alright.
I think I could.
Wait, that's good damage.
Yeah.
It's time.
It's time to make some walls.
Alright.
Nevermind.
I have to like make sure the armor is out.
You're a healer, don't you?
What did you expect?
Um.
How else am I gonna defend myself?
I may be a healer.
But like.
I need to defend myself.
My damage should be like ten times stronger.
than the DPS.
Um.
The DPS.
Yeah.
Healers need MVP too.
You know that, right?
The best support, is the support that can defend herself.
Alright.
No, you don't.
Yeah, it says.
Typical DPS player.
Doesn't want the healer to be able to self defend.
Oh, you want the support to be like.
Oh, DPS please.
Save me.
I am a strong independent support player.
I need no DPS to defend me.
Knock in boys.
I'm Nanak.TerLaugh.
I am naa.
List.
Save me, DPS!
I am a strong leader at.
Alright, here we go.
Time to play the quote-on-quote objective.
Okay, you can't yell at me for not playing objective when my mission is to just heal.
You can't... You can't blame me.
This is now all dependent on my team now.
Oh my god, I start in the water?
Oh wait, no, we're going out.
Oh, that's cool, actually.
Oh, it's car.
Oh, it's escort.
Oh, that's cool.
No, I got you.
I got you.
Oh, wait!
Who's got me?
Hello, support me!
Okay.
I'm going to support their detail.
Support player needs help, please.
Oh!
Did I help?
Oh, please!
Support player needs help!
Support!
Please!
Am I helping?
Oh!
No, wait, no, give it to me!
Give it to me!
I don't want to be support anymore!
I don't want to be support!
I don't like it.
Guys, I don't think...
I am the thing I'm meant to be a support in Mecha Freak.
I am...
You're fine.
I don't know, I can't tell!
I can't tell at all!
I don't know
what...
Wall!
I don't know how I'm alive!
I don't know.
I don't know...
Shit!
Oh, my god.
Where are they?
I should help them.
Don't worry.
I got you!
Double kill!
I don't know what I did, but double kill!
Don't worry.
I got you!
I got you, girl!
One!
Another one!
Look at all these wands!
Please!
He's coming for me, isn't he?
Okay.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
I got you.
There we go.
Oh my god.
Who's got me, though?
Who's got me?
Oh my god!
Please!
Someone come over here!
Oh, I got you!
There we go.
Oh my god, I leave!
Woo!
Wait, where's our cart?
Oh shit, it's over!
I forgot where our cart went!
I was like, where is it?
Don't worry!
There are walls!
All the walls!
All of it!
Look at all these walls, guys!
Okay, nice.
Don't keep these.
Oh my god!
It's just all walls!
All walls!
Bro, I can't tell what's going on anymore.
How did I get up here.
How did I... JK, it's all walls.
More walls!
There's so many walls!
Where am I?
It's just all walls!
That's right!
It's just walls.
There we go.
Nice.
Watch this!
What?
Oh wait, he's so far.
Did we win?
Did we- Did we- Get up here!
Okay.
Oh, I got you.
I got you!
You are at walls!
I was- I was struck before the token.
Wait, wait.
Were we doing bad?
Guys!
The thing is!
I can't even tell if we are doing bad.
Like, I don't know what's going on.
Don't worry, I've got you.
I'm healing.
I'm doing my job.
Oh my god.
Where's the objective?
Guys, I actually don't know where the objectives are.
I can't tell.
Am I...
Are we doing it?
Guys, are we doing it?
I can't tell.
Okay.
I think I am doing it.
I think I am.
Don't worry, I'll put down a wall just in case.
I'll put it down.
I think it's helping.
Assist.
My new team.
Yay!
We're winning!
I can't tell!
But yay!
We're doing it!
Okay, nice.
Nice.
I-I legitimately can't tell, so I'm glad.
I'm glad.
It's hard to tell.
It really is.
Build that wall.
I'll keep building walls!
Don't worry, everybody.
I'll keep building those walls!
We're doing it!
There's so many walls, but we're doing it.
Alright.
Alright, nice.
We're still doing it!
Jesus Christ, please!
Please just kill him!
Please!
I'm doing it!
Oh!
Don't let him get me!
Please!
I'm just the support!
Wow!
Okay, we're five.
Oh, so...
It's okay.
I built... I did it.
I did it.
Like, where's our car?
Is that our car?
Is that it?
Wait, what?
Wait, that's the enemy...
Where's our car?
Oh my god!
Our car is over...
Why were I...
Why were we fighting there?
For the longest...
Okay, I don't understand.
Wait, but why were we fighting there?
What?
I was just...
I literally stayed with my team!
Because they...
Everybody was there!
I don't understand!
If that was not...
I'm so confused!
Oh, I was preventing the enemy.
Okay, but if we just pushed our own car, we don't have to worry about that.
Yo, is that crazy for me to say that?
If we just pushed our own car, we'll never have to worry.
Yes, it is!
That's so controversial, why would you say that?
By standing...
Bro, like, all of us were standing there!
So I was like, wait!
Wait!
What was that?
That wasn't the car?
Okay.
Oh my god, I have no idea what the plan is for this guy.
Oh my god, their plan is to try and kill me.
I get it now.
I get it.
Oh my god, they really want me dead.
They really want me dead.
Yeah, I'm gonna heal.
Oh shit!
Yeah, I need...
Where am I?
Everything's fine.
Alright.
Am I helping?
I think I am?
I...
I think so.
We just need more walls.
There we go.
We did it.
I'm building a wall.
You can't get in now.
Perhaps...
I just needed...
I just needed more walls.
I'm doing it, guys.
There we go.
Sombra, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you, thank you.
I...
I don't know what was going...
I don't know what was going on.
But we did it.
Alright.
Nice topic.
26 assists.
I like tickled everybody.
Everybody was touched by me.
Omega, thank you for the five gifted subs.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright.
400...
Okay, I did like 268 in repair.
That was a lot.
I was literally...
Oh my god!
Bro, how do you die?
Okay, we were like just farming them at that point.
Okay, wait.
Let's see.
What's the...
Is there like reverse advance?
Okay, there's no like kills.
But like, I feel like we were just...
We were just farming these people over and over again.
Yeah, you...
I farmed under...
Yeah, I feel like we forgot to do our own objective.
We were literally...
We were literally just...
We were literally just shooting their card for three minutes straight.
And I was so confused.
I was like...
Is this how you play the game?
I was so confused.
For it...
Yeah.
We literally were like...
On the...
Cause I was like...
Why...
Why aren't we moving?
I...
Like only one person...
I think only one person...
But like the thing is...
Everyone was like on their own.
I didn't know which one was the card.
I'm so confused.
Okay.
Alright, nice.
Alright.
I don't know.
I don't know how...
I think...
Legitimately...
I don't think...
I think like...
For...
Mecha break...
Uh...
Almost a million damage.
And no deaths.
Yeah.
But I didn't know which...
Like where the card was.
I couldn't tell.
I was so fucking confused.
I couldn't tell where the card was.
Wait.
Which one is the other grid support?
Yeah it is.
Uh...
Which one?
Yeah.
We turned it into TDM.
Which one was the other grid support guys?
Lumine?
Okay.
Let me see.
Where is she?
Lu...
Lumine.
Okay.
We gotta see the little animation.
Smokescreen.
Oh.
Interesting.
Okay.
Field maintenance.
Oh.
She has wings too.
Nice.
That's cute.
Good.
All right.
Before we try her out.
I'm gonna use the bathroom real quick.
I'll be right back guys.
Back.
I'm back everyone.
All right.
I'm gonna do one more.
Okay.
Uh...
We'll do...
One more game.
Try out this other support.
And then we're gonna do custom lobbies after that.
So you guys wanna join in?
You can download, uh...
Mecha Break right now.
Which is free to play.
By clicking the link.
Uh...
That's pinned in the chat.
Or do an exclamation point Mecha Break.
And then click on my link.
And you can dial it.
Because it's a free to play game!
Yay!
Because after this game, we're gonna try to do custom lobbies chat.
Um...
All right.
Let me try out her kit.
I'm back.
Hello, hello everyone.
I am back.
Uh...
All right.
Let's see what her kit is like.
Thank you guys.
Thank you for liking my new outfit.
Back at school.
All right.
Ooh!
I like how she has wings.
Like that the support mechas actually look like support.
All right.
Drone launchers.
Portions of friendly units age pre- and provide continuous repairs.
If no effect applies to...
Deploys tracking drone on an enemy unit.
Wait, how do I know it's...
Uh...
That bypasses...
On enemy units and damage that bypasses...
That applies to the caster.
I don't know which one is...
Okay.
I am using...
Oh!
An automatic...
Okay.
I get it.
I get it now.
I just have to like...
Okay.
So...
Um...
It's one ammo.
One...
Like they're both the same gun.
But it's like whichever one...
Okay.
I get it.
It's whichever one I like...
Bump into.
Yeah.
So like...
If there's like an enemy in front of me...
It'll like...
Go towards them.
But if I'm on an island...
Like...
If I do this...
And then I could...
Wait, what?
Is that not it?
Or do I swap it?
I have to swap?
Wait, what?
Wait, how do I...
Oh!
I have to swap it.
Okay.
Oh, I see.
I see now.
Do they stack?
Or is it only two?
I think it's only two.
Yeah.
Only two.
Okay.
Deployers a smoke stream that continuously repairs friendly use it.
Deployers that continuously inflict physical damage.
Revenge.
Okay.
Oh, this is a lot of swapping.
Oh...
Okay.
Yeah, this is a...
A lot...
Uh...
There's a lot of...
There's a lot of thinking for this.
Yeah, like...
It's like basically a lot of shit going on.
Hahaha!
Sagger while increasing.
Cancels.
Immolite.
Disrupts enemies fire.
Press...
Oh my god.
Yeah, this is a lot...
Like a lot of micromanaging for sure.
Like if I want to do support and stuff.
And then I just spam everything.
And then I'd be like...
Pew pew pew pew pew pew pew.
Pew pew pew pew pew.
Pew pew pew pew.
Hahaha!
Oh, there's a lot.
Yeah.
It's definitely gonna get...
A little complex.
I'll try.
I'll try it out.
There's a lot of thinking.
Complete.
Yeah.
If you're forcing this, you need to use Crow.
Otherwise, hope your teammates can save you.
Yeah, this is a...
A lot of thinking for sure.
Uh...
We'll try...
I think I'm gonna get like...
Fucking...
Uh...
Overwhelmed.
100%.
I feel like.
I think my...
I'm gonna get overloaded with info for this.
I'm...
I think so.
Yeah, a lot of positioning too.
I think a lot of them are like close...
You have to use like close range too.
For like the corruption stuff.
So it's gonna be like a lot of thinking.
For this game mode in general.
Which might be bad.
Hahaha!
Cuz...
Cuz I don't think.
Hahaha!
I don't think.
So I don't know.
Possibly.
Hahaha!
Alright.
Lumine is here.
Ready to strike.
Narukami.
Alright.
I'm gonna look at your...
I'm gonna analyze you.
Oh, it's cuz we're in bronze.
That's like 8 total kill.
Hahaha!
Panther.
Ready to strike.
Go bang.
Alright.
How many games have you played?
Oh, we're all in bronze ELO.
Hello everybody.
Wait, how the fuck did that other guy join my lobby that one time?
The fucking GM guy.
What the fuck?
How did he hack his way in?
I'm in the lobby with actual bronze players.
I need to stand.
Oh, my brain is gonna be so overwhelmed.
Yeah, thank you for the hundred biddies.
Thank you, thank you.
Hi from Anime Expo.
Hello!
Also Tatsu, thank you for tier one sub.
Thank you.
Secure two out of three rounds of attack to suppress the enemy.
Alright, here we go.
Here we go.
My brain- my brain is already overwhelmed.
Like we're- like thinking about the things I have to do.
I'm already- I'm already like- Oh shit.
Like I'm thinking about it.
Get me in.
Let me in!
The common area is divided.
Eliminate eight enemies to win the round.
The first squad to win- Oh, okay.
It's elimination.
Let's do this!
Oh my god.
Why can't my objectives just be elimination?
Let's do this!
Here I go!
Why did they win Ungabunga?
Okay, no.
You don't understand.
It can't all just- Despite how much I would love it to just be Ungabunga.
Sometimes.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
I'm already overwound!
Oh my god.
Guys, I'm already overwhelmed!
She's scared.
I can't, I can't.
Okay, holy shit.
Just press the button.
I'm so healthy.
Okay, guys.
Okay, I might, may or may not, may or may not like this character.
After you die, cause I went in corruption mode for one second.
That's out.
Apparently.
Wait.
There we go.
Oh my god, he DC'd.
Guys, this is my time.
This is my time to shine.
He DC'd.
This is it.
Oh my god!
What the fuck?!
Oh!
Oh, is everybody shooting me?!
Oh no!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, please!
Somebody!
Oh, you're point!
You're point, support!
Oh my god!
Oh
my god!
Oh my god!
Please!
Get me out of here!
That's it, I'm angry!
I'm angry!
I am...
I'm...
I'm angry now!
I'm so...
I don't know, I've never played this map before, to be fair.
So I'm like, a lot more...
Guys, I don't think we're gonna win this round.
Oh my god.
I don't know.
I can't tell.
Please!
AHHHHH!
That's
a person!
Oh my god!
I swear to god!
Oh my god, please!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, please, for the love of god!
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna stay near you!
I...
I get her!
Bro, it's fine!
I'm fine!
Napkins, thank you!
Within Twitch Prime, thank you!
Thank you!
Bro!
What do I do?
What do I...
This is fine!
Bro, I can't even go into corruption mode!
I'm fucking getting hunted down like crazy!
That's crazy!
Oh, bro!
We're gonna...
We're gonna hang out together!
I'm gonna hang out with you together!
Don't worry!
We're gonna...
Oh my god!
This is it!
No way!
Oh my god!
Get me out of this open!
Get me out of here!
Get me out!
Oh my...
Get me out of here!
Oh my god.
Get me out of here.
I can't leave it.
Oh my god, get me out of here.
Where's my team?
Where is this?
Where are they?
I can't stop.
I keep getting haunted.
I'm running around.
Where's the safety?
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
I'm literally just running.
I'm just dodging everything.
I'm dodging everything possible.
It's actually crazy.
My entire life is just survive.
I'm just trying to survive right now.
Don't worry, I got you.
I don't know for how long.
But I got you.
Bro.
Oh my god.
I swear I can't even... I can't even do corruption mode.
Okay, wait.
Maybe unless... Okay, no.
It's actually not a good idea.
At all.
It's not a good idea.
You guys better be shooting.
You guys better be doing something because I don't know what's going on.
Oh my god.
I... Oh my god.
Please.
You have two heels.
I'm doing everything I can to keep you up.
I'm... I'm... I have not stopped moving.
I... Guys, the only way to live is just to keep flying.
Just keep flying.
Oh my god.
We did it.
Okay.
Maybe I can do one.
Oh my god.
I stopped.
I... I had... I hesitated.
I asked.
Oh my god.
What am I doing?
No.
Okay.
It's fine.
At least she's in this track.
Just keep flying.
Nothing can hurt you if you just keep flying.
I mean... Nothing can hurt you.
Jus keep flying.
Here we go.
There we go.
Just keep flying.
We got this!
Oh, shit!
It's fine.
Oh my god, I was like, freaking out.
Okay.
I don't like this character.
He dodged us!
I don't know!
At the moment, I never stopped moving.
I never stopped moving.
And that was, like, the only way for me to live.
Wait, bro, like, I just... I never stopped.
I never stopped moving.
The moment I stood still, for one second, I get, like, fucking shot at.
If I ever... Look at this!
Like, what is this?
What is that?
Okay, look.
What the fuck?
What?
What am I going through?
What am I going...
That's how it is.
I totally...
That was terrible.
That was actually...
That was actually, like...
That was so miserable.
Playing that character.
Oh my god.
I did...
I was so...
I did so much healing, too.
I...
I got blasted by everybody.
But I still...
I still did.
Bro, this guy took a million damage.
Oh my god.
Well done.
Okay.
All right.
I know I said I would do...
But I need to play a game with DPS.
I can't.
That...
I need to play a game with DPS after that.
That was fucking crazy.
That was actually crazy.
I can't.
Get her.
I felt like I couldn't...
The moment I stopped moving...
Like, I legitimately just got like...
You know, like...
Like a thumb just came down and just squished me.
That's...
That's how it felt like.
I earned the DPS run here.
I deserve to play DPS after what happened to me.
I...
I deserve this.
I felt like an ant in that world.
Like the thumb was just ready to squish me.
And I was just running away from the giant ass thumb.
Like, I couldn't...
I couldn't even use the corruption mode.
Because like, everybody was shooting me.
Oh, this guy's gonna play Luminae.
Fucking good luck, buddy.
Good fucking luck.
That's the guy that hates themselves.
They hate themselves right now.
Alright, here we go.
I'm ready.
I'm actually...
I'm a lot more ready than that support.
Bro, okay.
The other...
What's the other support?
The pen...
Whatever her name is.
She was like...
I didn't know what I was doing.
But like, I felt more safe with her.
I felt like...
I could actually like...
Fight back.
Penaka.
Yeah.
I felt like I could...
I could actually like...
Sort of.
And I had walls.
Alright, here we go.
I love...
I love this character.
I don't know.
She's really fun to play.
Oh my god.
See the hood...
The guy...
The hood's mech.
And their pilot.
The customization's pretty good, though.
I like the customization options.
Alright, come on.
Load in, everybody.
Approach Coralright Extractors.
This will be the first to reach specific numbers.
Oh my god.
Every time I actually do that.
Like, every time it's a kill objective...
Um...
Game, I'm not a DPS.
Alright.
Dismantled Coralright Extractors to prevent Coralright Pulse Storm.
Here we go.
That's right.
Alright.
Come on.
Let's go.
I want a frag!
I'm mad!
I'm here to frag!
Oh wait.
Someone else has to do objective, not me, though.
Guys, I can't.
Ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha!
Someone else has to do objective, and it's not me!
Oh my god.
Please.
Please!
I'm just a sniper!
You cannot expect a sniper to do that.
Oh.
Fuck.
Here we go.
Come on.
Get over here!
Oh my god.
Get over here.
You're solo.
You're actually solo.
Here we go.
He's one hit.
Stereo.
Because someone else has to do objective, and it's not me.
Come on, guys!
Guys, come on!
Oh, there's another Nurukami here, too.
Ha ha ha.
Oh, where are you?
Over here.
I see you.
Where did she go?
I don't see you anymore.
Oh, shit.
Where did she go?
Where did the other Nurukami go?
I know that I'm not supposed to frontline.
But, like, it's just more fun.
Oh my god.
Are you serious?
Please!
Damn!
Can you do the objective?
Please!
Frontline is just more fun.
I don't know.
I find the frontline fights more fun as Nurukami.
It's more...
I don't know.
I guess because I'm closer to the action.
I don't have ammo.
Ha ha ha ha.
Fine.
I guess I can do this.
Guys, please!
Can someone else...
Oh my god.
Oh my...
My team doesn't like doing objectives, guys.
There we go.
He kneeled.
Oh my god.
That would...
That would've been so cool if that hit.
There we go.
That's fine.
No help.
Please, team.
Team, please!
Team...
There we go.
Fine.
I'll play non...
I'll play...
You're over here, Panther.
I see you.
Oh, it would be cool if I hit that.
Wait, where's the... Guys!
Guys, the boss is already here!
Oh my god, guys, please!
Are we all
so...
Woo!
Oh, he got the wrong one.
Wrong one, sucker.
That's right, that was my clone.
Are you serious?
Oh my god, okay, I distracted him.
Okay, nice.
Okay.
Nice, all right, we're five.
I was gonna say, no one is near... no one's at the objective.
It's actually crazy.
Okay.
I wanted two at least over there.
Hello, guys.
Okay.
Oh, no.
I have to use my non-sniper arm for this.
Okay, nice.
Whoa!
Where did he come from?
I, like, unscoped.
But I think he missed.
I unscoped, and he was right next to me.
I think that guy actually missed.
There's no way.
I was like, where did he come from?
That guy did not miss.
Okay.
Nice.
Don't worry, they don't know.
They'll never expect me on the ground.
That's the best part.
They don't...
They don't expect me on the ground.
Okay.
Where's the other deploy...
Okay, guys.
Come on.
What the fuck?
Who do I shoot at?
Oh, her.
I was gonna say, like, who...
Okay, nice.
That's fucking right.
Oh, that's a clone.
Oh.
I don't think he knows.
I don't know what she was doing.
She just sit there?
Did she think I...
Oh, she thought I was the clone, maybe.
Maybe she thought...
I don't know.
I don't ask questions anymore.
Did she think I was the clone?
Maybe?
Okay.
There we go.
I'll grab two here.
Bro, I'm not like...
Oh, there she is.
Where's the other...
I know you're here.
I know.
Oh, shit!
Okay, okay.
She almost baited me.
She actually almost got me there.
Okay, that was good.
That was...
They learned.
They knew.
This time.
Fight.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay, but I really need heals, though.
Heals, don't go.
Please.
Oh, thank God.
Actually, no.
Oh, my God.
Please.
He wants me.
He wants me so bad.
Oh, I know you're here.
He knows.
Oh, he knows.
He knows what I have.
Yeah.
I know what you are.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh, my God.
We actually turned it around.
Way to throw that one away.
Oh, my God.
I did not expect us to turn that around, thank god.
Nice, who was it?
AHHHHH!
Oh my god.
Tiny bites.
For tiny faces.
Little bites, sorry.
Little bites are little faces.
Oh, thank you for the kudos, Dildo.
Thank you.
We won.
GG.
Yeah, I was talking shit to them.
Love you.
Kiss me.
Love you too.
Oh my god, I love you too.
Make out with us.
Yeah.
Two men, two men.
Same shit, different day.
Alright, that guy, that guy deserves the kudos.
Where is he?
Dildo.
You're not even a...
Wait!
Oh my...
Wait, that was their Nurukami?
Bro!
It's so sad.
That was their Nurukami.
I, like, copied their strat because I was like, I want a frontline, but I guess I can do range.
Uh...
That's, I had no...
It was because I looked straight at him.
I didn't run away.
What do you mean?
I let him fully charge the Sniper ran on me because I was like, I'm not, I was like, I'm not threatened by it.
That's crazy.
Crazy.
Oh my god.
That's actually insane.
Alright.
Alright, let's do custom lobbies, guys.
Yay.
They are just learning.
Alright, let's see.
Tactical station.
Custom room.
Alright, I'm creating a room right now.
We'll do random.
Wait, is this arena?
Sorry, let me reset this room.
Sorry, guys.
We're resetting this room.
You gotta try again.
It's time to try again.
Okay, I wanna do... Okay, random map.
Operation version.
Okay, random map.
Random map.
Operation.
Okay, we'll do...
We'll do Operation version first.
So that more people can play.
Boop.
Alright, here we go.
Alright, now we... Now you guys can join in.
I don't know which one to play.
Uh...
Let's see.
Yeah, this is the code.
Room number.
489817.
Okay, it's done.
Okay, that was fast.
Wait.
What map is this?
What map?
Okay, actually... No, let's... Let's get... Let's get... Uh...
I just realized.
I was thinking.
I don't wanna do... Okay, actually, no.
It's gonna be forever.
Let's do a map that's not forever.
Um...
Which one was the... Which one was the...
Cart, guys?
Which one was the cart?
Because I liked that one.
That one was fun.
I just remembered that they have objective... Which one's... Oh, wait.
Actually, to make it easier... Which one are objective maps?
Because fuck that shit.
Uh...
Palm Bay Harbor?
Okay, which one are the objective maps?
Because we're getting rid of those.
We're gonna get rid of those.
Cart is not objective.
Okay, the one where it's like points.
Oh, launch site and harbor cards.
Okay, launch site.
Which one did we do?
I think we didn't do launch site yet.
Alright, we'll do that.
Alright, start.
Alright.
I don't know.
Okay, I wanna swap.
Uh, we'll try...
We'll try...
Let's try the Aquila sniper again.
I'll try her.
Aquila!
I'm ready to strike.
Yeah, this is NA servers.
Because I'm in NA.
Bro.
You think I'm gonna debuff myself in my own server?
It's just like...
Alright, guys.
Let me start...
Let me start playing on 200 ping on my own server.
Like...
The logic.
Let me just...
I don't know.
Let's swap my server to Asia real quick.
Because, you know...
I'd like the challenge.
Alright, I'm ready.
Alright.
I'm ready to snipe.
Plus, I gotta make it fair, Toki.
Aquila.
That's me.
I'm Aquila.
Hello, everybody.
I'm ready.
Squirt dish payload.
Alright.
I now know the objective, guys.
I already forgot how to play this character, though.
I'm gonna play this character again.
Oh my god!
He's just twirling!
Oh my god.
He's just twirling.
Guys, what was one?
I don't remember.
Oh wait.
Oh, I remember now.
Oh my god.
It's fine.
I got you.
Oh, it's him!
It's...
Oh, I don't got you anymore.
You're not spinning anymore.
Oh, you...
I don't got you anymore.
I'm trying my best to get you.
But I think you're dead.
You're so dead.
Oh my god.
He has it again?
Oh, I'm sorry.
You're so dead.
Okay.
I don't know how I did it.
Oh, thank God.
I got saved.
Oh my god.
He's one.
We're fine.
Oh, babe.
Let it rip.
He really let it rip.
Oh my god.
Please.
He's spinning so much.
Wait.
I got it.
Can't spin now.
That's right.
What you gotta do?
Stop the spin.
Okay.
I'm okay.
I feel so healthy.
Guys, I don't feel healthy anymore.
I don't...
I feel so healthy.
Oh my god.
Everybody is just twerling.
Oh!
Let me out.
Let me out!
Initiating ejection sequence.
Oh my god.
There's so many people.
Everybody was...
Roll out.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Yeah.
No.
I was not living there.
Getting in that mech.
Are we pushing?
I don't know.
All right.
I'm gonna go in there and see.
Oh yeah.
We're not even...
Yeah.
We're...
We're a little...
It's a little bit...
It's a little bit scary right now.
Fine.
I stunned him.
I did my jump.
Oh my god.
Wow!
Okay.
Guys.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Goodbye.
I need a...
Please.
I need healing.
No!
I need healing!
Support, please!
Oh my god, who is Qukies?
I'm getting tired.
Save me some Lord Saad.
What do I do?
A DDS.
I do it.
I do.
Why should I play Durukavi?
I do it.
Why did I get out of my main?
Why did I ever swap off my main?
I knew it.
Oh my god.
So low.
Nice.
That's goddamn right, you clown.
That's goddamn right.
Okay, I'm just gonna stay up here.
I feel right safe.
I feel... I want to be safe today.
I...
Oh, they tried to... Oh my god, they tried to flank me.
Oh my god.
Oh, they tried to flank me.
They almost got me.
They got me.
They actually got me.
I don't know what's hitting me, but they got me.
I don't know what's hitting me.
Please.
Medic.
I don't know.
I need healing.
I need healing!
What's the controls?
What's the controls for it?
Guys, I don't know what the controls are for I need healing.
I'm trapped.
Please, there's one.
Please!
I'm over here!
I need healing!
Holy shit, that guy is human.
Oh my god.
Where's my... Where is... Where are they?
Okay, that's fine.
One HP and a dream.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I'm just...
Please, I need healing myself.
I don't know how I live for this life.
I don't know.
I should be dead.
I guess my tiff was greatly exaggerated.
Oh my god.
Is that a heal?
They found... I don't know how I survived that long.
But they found me.
I spoke too soon.
I spoke way too soon.
They were like...
I got hunted down.
Yeah, I got fucking hunted down.
Heal dead murdered.
They hunted me down.
They waited until I...
They waited until I felt safe.
They're like...
Oh, you feel safe, don't you?
You feel...
I felt so safe.
I felt really, really safe.
Oh my god.
They're like flying everywhere.
I don't feel safe anymore!
I feel...
I don't feel safe.
I really don't.
Oh, please.
Oh my god, please.
I don't know.
I'm just...
I'm literally just flying away.
I don't know.
I'm literally...
Where's...
Guys?
Where's my luminaire?
Luminaire Luigi!
I'm trying to like take cover, but I can't!
OH MY GOD!
Are you fucking kidding me?
I literally can't fucking...
FREEZE!
Just okay.
I just need...
I need a chill.
I...
I'm shooting me down!
Oh my god!
I'm actually gonna do this.
Oh...
The hunter...
Has become the hunted.
That's fucking right you are!
Not so badass now!
Right?
That's right!
Not so badass now, are ya?
That's goddamn right!
That's fucking...
It's not so funny now, is it?
It's not that funny now!
That's right!
Fuck you!
Nooo!
Actual fuck you!
What?
Let's try it!
Not so funny now!
When they fight back!
That's fucking right!
I fight back now!
I see her too!
Oh, I know you're still around!
Oh, you're such a bitch!
Ha ha ha!
Stupid!
Fucker!
Oh my god!
We won!
We actually won!
Ha ha ha ha!
We did!
Oh, that thing!
Ha ha ha!
We actually won!
Holy shit!
I was just...
Oh my god!
After getting hunted down!
Non-stop!
Yay!
I was like, yippee!
I pushed the cart!
Guys!
I did it!
I...
Ha ha ha!
Oh my god!
I was just running so much!
Ha ha ha!
700k!
Damn it!
Take it!
Like, can you blame me with the shit I just went through?
I, like, we weren't even...
We only had one guy!
That got the, like, leaderboard!
Like, they...
Your team did not do the objectives!
You're...
Ha ha ha!
You guys don't know!
You guys actually had...
The leaderboard!
Ha ha ha!
But you did not do the objectives!
That's crazy!
We should not have won that game!
We should not have won!
Ha ha ha!
They were just chasing us!
Look at...
Holy shit!
We had two players!
With two million damage taken!
It's about sending the message!
Oh my god!
Now there was a million...
A million...
Let's...
Create...
Let's create a...
TDM lobby!
Alright!
Create room!
Now it's TDM time!
Uh...
Alright!
I'm gonna use the bathroom real quick!
I'll be right back!
I hydrated a lot!
Ha ha ha!
So if you played already!
Um...
Let other drag wounds have a chance to play!
Because I can only play like...
I think like...
One more after this!
One more custom lobby!
Alright!
So if you've been in the lobby...
And like...
Chat!
You can rack them out to me!
If...
You see someone that's been in the lobby before!
I'm back!
I got my food too!
So I was like...
Grabbing that!
That's why I came over!
And then I disappeared again!
Alright!
Give me a sec!
Let me have like...
One little food break guys!
Just a tiny bit!
Because...
Because I didn't eat anything yet!
Ha ha ha!
Just one little food break before we...
Go game again!
Woah!
Woah, woah, woah!
I got curry!
Oh!
It smells so good!
Mmm-hmm, mmmm-hmm, mmmm...
I got um...
I got like...
Um!
Mmm, beef curry.
Mmm.
Japanese beef curry.
I haven't had this in a while, too.
I'm gonna treat myself.
Oh, tonight?
To celebrate?
Um... Because I haven't had, like, um, actual, like, from a birthday present to myself.
I'm going to a Michelin star restaurant.
Today.
The, like, I have a birthday present to myself.
I'm treating myself.
I haven't met a Michelin star restaurant in so long.
Oh, wait.
The last time, I, like, um, fucked up.
Oh, wait, no.
I went to one in Japan, and I fucked up, because, like, um, I wanted to go to any Michelin star restaurant, but because, like, the place I went to, I told you guys the story.
Yeah, it was the mushroom story.
Yeah!
Like, and, like, I went to Japanese, like, Michelin star restaurant.
But it's like a set menu, so you can't order individually.
And then all I... it was mushroom season.
And then everything they gave me was just mushroom.
Like, almost all the dishes were mostly mushroom.
And I hate mushrooms.
I don't like mushrooms at all.
I was like, no!
I paid so much.
And they're like, they saw me not eat a lot.
I'm like, oh, is something wrong with the food?
I was like, no, I just don't like it.
I'm sorry.
It's so, it's so good.
Om yom yom.
I feel bad.
I'm like, no, no.
I mean, it's so good.
Om yom yom.
I paid so much because it's a set menu.
Yeah, so, but yeah, this time it's different.
This time it's different.
It's food I actually like.
Um, I won't say much about it.
It's like, um, I don't want to dox myself.
But like, it's those types of restaurants that like, only serve like, very limited people.
Like per day.
So like, they only serve like, like, they only serve for like, um, very limited people.
So like, um, so it's, it's more so of like, oh, um, and it's like, also like, set price too.
Um, but yeah, but that's all the details I'll give.
I'm like, looking forward to it.
I booked this place for like, um, cause I'm like, oh my God.
How do they, I guess like, sometimes like, how do they make their money back?
Like there's so little people.
And it's just like, they only do like, like dinner.
That's it.
Like, like.
You only do dinner and it's like, limited.
But I booked it in advance for a while.
So.
I'm excited.
I'm so excited.
I'm not gonna eat much for lunch.
I know I ordered like, um, I only ordered like, um, um, I ordered Japanese curry, but I'm not gonna eat all of it.
Cause I want to save my stomach for tonight.
It must be expensive, expensive.
Yeah.
And I made sure this time, cause it's all in English.
I made sure that it's not, that it's not mushrooms.
This time, I learned.
I, I'm treating myself.
And I learned that it's not, oops, all mushrooms.
All mushrooms.
All mushroom season for me.
Alright, one more bite.
Sorry, this is actually really good.
Mmm.
Okay.
I'm ready.
That's really good.
No, it's not.
It's not depressing.
I do that a lot.
Cause I'm an only child.
And like, I don't know.
You don't have to socialize with people.
You can just like, go and eat something nice for yourself.
You know?
I don't.
Eat alone is not that bad.
Mmm.
Alright, here you go.
You don't have to like, you know, socialize with people.
You just enjoy the meal.
And you can like, you know.
You know, it's not rude to like, be on your phone and stuff too.
Cause it's just, you're just by yourself.
Like.
So I can literally like.
Sometimes I like, you know, watch a show or something while I'm eating.
And I'm like, you know.
Sometimes I rather prefer just watching a show while I'm eating.
Like, you know?
Alright.
Are you guys ready?
Yes, we're ending.
Okay, Peter's like, we can only do one game.
So we're ending it on 3v3.
Yes.
You guys want to try out Mecha.
I will be doing one more Mecha Break stream.
Let's end it with Nurukami.
That's right.
I'm bringing out the hot girl.
Uh.
The hot one.
Nurukami is ready to strike.
That's fucking right.
The only, yeah.
The only issue about eating alone is that like.
Um.
The only times I can actually like eat hot pot.
Or like Korean barbecue.
Is if I'm like, you know, with people.
And that's the worst part.
Like.
I once did Korean barbecue by myself.
And it was so sad.
Because I was like.
Oh, can I like.
Do you have like.
Can we like split half this order?
Um.
Because like.
That's a lot.
And you're like.
No.
You have to order a two person combo.
I was like.
Oh.
I was just like.
Um.
Do you have any combos for one?
For Korean barbecue?
And they're like.
Nope.
There's only two person combos here.
And I was like.
OK.
And if I really want to see Kree in 5... WHAT IS THIS?
OH MY GOD!
I PICKED THE WRONG!
Holy shit!
What is this map?
That's so rough.
That's a rough map right here.
We're ending it on the practice map.
Fuck it.
Okay, that's cool.
It actually changes too.
That's so cool.
That's pretty cool actually.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, the map changes.
Okay, I was gonna say.
That's so fucked up if it's literally just...
That'd be so fucked up, you know?
If it's just an open area.
In general.
Okay.
Alright.
Let's see.
Woah!
I don't even know I'm here.
Yeah.
Nice.
Okay, nice.
Hit.
Alright.
Let's fire.
Oh shit!
The wall!
Holy shit!
I've got walls.
Oh my god.
I actually got squashed.
Oh my- I was not expecting that.
Okay.
Whoa!
The scary part is that like, I'm 1 HP, so like...
So like, that's scary.
I'm a little itty bitty spider short and shtop.
Here is my candle and here is my...
I like mixed up two nursery rhyme songs.
Oh my god, he died for it.
He died for it, that's fine.
He died for it, for his sins.
I survived so loud with 1 HP.
I did.
I was not supposed to be alive.
Wait, what?
Oh, wait, they have a Nurukami too!
Okay.
Oh, I got you, buddy.
I got you, baby.
Wait, yeah!
That's right!
We got final kill on you!
That's goddamn right!
That's right!
Woo!
We win that!
Look at that!
I won my last two games!
I don't know if I did anything.
But that's okay.
Nice!
It doesn't matter!
You know what?
Well, I like that we ended on that.
Perfect!
Calculated!
That's right!
I purposely did not do more or less.
So we can end on a good number.
Nice!
Yes!
Anyways.
I'm gonna call it here.
Because we do have another Mecha Break stream.
The last one for Twitch Drops on Tuesday.
So if you still haven't got your Twitch Drops yet, for those who don't know, we're new here.
Here are the Twitch Drops where you can be a cat girl.
So if you haven't got it yet, I will still be streaming Mecha Break on Tuesday.
Sponsored by Mecha Break.
Again, huge thank you to the sponsor for sponsoring me.
And if you want to try out the game right now, it is free to play.
So basically you can download it right now.
And we'll do more custom lobbies on Tuesday too.
So it's your chance to play with me more on Tuesday.
You can click on the link in the description.
Not description, sorry.
Pin in the chat.
Or do exclamation point Mecha Break.
For those who are new here, my name is DokiBear.
And I usually stream on YouTube.
But today I'm on Twitch for the sponsor for the Twitch Drops.
But if you want to know whenever I stream on Twitch, feel free to follow me on Twitter.
exclamation point social slash Twitter.
Or, you know, one or the other.
And also, we recently launched our merch store.
And we have a birthday bundle.
So if you want to support me and buy the birthday bundle, Please feel free to do exclamation point merch.
And check out my new merch merchandise.
Yeah!
We have a lot of new store stuff.
A lot of new items that launch too.
And like we have some that's already in the warehouse.
So if you want some items right now to be shipped like now, you can buy them there on the store.
But thank you everybody!
Um, okay, for those who are wondering from pre-order windows, I forgot to ask the staff about that.
But I will ask them like, uh, after the stream.
Anyway, guys.
Uh, thank you again all for coming.
As always, everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed cause you deserve it!
Thank you again for all the subs!
The follows!
The biddies!
The...
What else is there on Twitch?
The raids!
Yes!
Thank you again everyone!
I always appreciate the support!
I'll see you guys next time everyone!
Bye guys!
Bye!
No stream tomorrow!
I'm chillin'!
Bye!